The Soviets,
given their idea of class guilt,
which sounds a lot like white privilege
to me or any other form of racism,
they use that doctrine to just round up
all the kulaks they were the productive
farmers and ship them off to Siberia and
then 6 million Ukrainian starved to
death.
But you know,
they had too many Ukrainians anyway,
so it didn't really matter.
So anyways,
back to the postmodern types.
Well,
you know,
this all came was revealed in such
painful detail that even the kind of
closed minded idealogue that Norman
referred to just quite,
couldn't,
couldn't quite muster up the moral
courage to keep beating the same damn
drum.
So what they did instead being highly
intelligent individuals,
was play a game of sleight of hand and
transformed these Marxist
presuppositions into postmodernism in
the 19 seventies.
And the idea basically was,
well,
the working class isn't going to rise up
and crushed the bourgeoisie because
first of all they're getting rich and
that wasn't supposed to happen.
And second,
well it sort of seemed to be a
catastrophe when that occurred,
let's say in Russia.
And so maybe we won't do that anymore
because the working class actually isn't
buying into this either,
which is also a problem,
you know,
having internalized their own
oppression,
they wouldn't buy into this,
to the global myth of Utopia.
So maybe it's because they've had some
sense.
It's certainly possible.
But anyways,
the slight of hand was,
oh,
well fine,
we'll just play a different one.
Oppressor versus oppressed game and
we'll introduce identity politics.
It's like,
okay,
you're not being oppressed because of
you're a member of the working class.
You're being oppressed because you're a
woman or you're being oppressed because
you have an ethnicity that's outside the
main paradigm,
whatever that might be.
Um,
or it's because of your,
your,
your sexual preference or your sexual
identity or whatever.
Whatever places you in some manner
outside the normative culture.
You know,
the thing is the postmodernist,
you know,
you might think,
well,
your culture is good for something.
It gives you a hierarchy of value.
It rewards competent people,
it gives you a direction so you can
climb up,
you know,
because otherwise everything's leveled
to nothing.
And then why do anything?
They don't care about any of that.
They don't believe that there's any such
thing as competence.
thing as up.
This is all postmodernism wipes,
all of that out.
And so when the postmodernists analyze
the text,
all they care about is how it privileges
the position of the author and who had
impresses.
And that's the only thing they regard as
real.
And they don't believe in grand unifying
narratives.
They don't believe that there's a
Canadian identity.
They don't believe that there's an
American identity.
They don't believe that there is a
western identity.
They don't believe that value structures
exist,
or if they are,
they're replaceable with some other
value structure.
They certainly don't believe that they
have any biological grounding.
That there's any such thing as a human
being.
It's all socially constructed,
which is really convenient.
If what you want to do is be the author
of an entirely social constructed you
utopia that you can run.